Paul I have to ask you as a director and
as a guy who's a writer - if you were a
writer no poor guy Paul is the right
rush if you were making a film right and
some some kid who's got one line in the
say a comedian has one line in the film
he's one yeah and right before you start
filming he approaches you and he's
rewritten the entire script to create
himself as a co-star and he goes hey
Paul I just had a couple ideas once you
let me know what you think of this I
rewrote it it happened it has happened
have you had anybody do it oh yeah how
do you handle that usually with brutal
honesty you know and occasionally
profanity
good but the other thing happens - which
is you have you know add a player with
one or two lines and you pull them aside
earlier in the day and say hey you know
there's not much here you two guys
you're playing cops you want to work out
something together and show it to me I'd
be you know maybe maybe we can make it
more interesting yeah see is because
Colin Quinn Crocodile Dundee - but I was
in crocodile 92 Idol line so I took the
script I read it found it a little
wanting cut out Charles Dutton I made
myself the co-star with all goodness a
1987 whatever and then I handed it in
the pay one line I handed it to the
director and a producer and they waited
for their response I literally sat there
like it made it more of like a New York
type thing with me and Paul Hogan
running around because it was New York
he's realized what a horse's ass he is
and they they just kind of you know they
will astray instead of like yeah you
know about it I was like I saw the movie
I was like look at these guys they blew
it like they could have done my version
do you think that was rude of them not
to get back to him I I think very
gracious they even accept it yeah yeah
yeah I would have I would have
definitely fired me in retrospect well
the time
like what have you found out that you
are on a movie set with somebody of the
audacity of a young Colin Quinn to do
something like that do you just not want
to deal with him yeah it's creepy yeah
if you the guy who tried to write
himself out but uh yeah and my poor
girlfriend typing it away like acid
giving little lines having me type
replace I'm into rope-a-dope you are
yeah just let him make the mistakes keep
going keep going keep going and then
eventually he'll just be out of your
life that makes sense
that makes sense